thank you
[Music]
guys know what about the LA Philharmonic
it is a structure that has been designed
to give you the best auditor experience
you could ever have at a concert I've
never been then the the Walt Disney
Concert Hall yeah okay
um
funny story about the LA Philharmonic I
remember I used to take the subway in La
I got off the subway one day and I saw
these lights and I started walking and
walking walking along like all these
lights all this cable
a lot of like equipment and sure enough
I walk up to a set and I look right here
and I'm like that's [__] Robert
Downey Jr in a tuxedo standing in front
of a futuristic Audi and they were
filming the first Iron Man movie at the
LA Philharmonic wow the the scene where
he's like talking to the Press yeah I
was just like on set randomly because I
just got the subway and I was it was
like right by my place in Koreatown and
I was like what the [__] going on at
the Philharmonic but it's a beautiful
building and during a recent concert
a woman
reportedly had a loud and quote full
body orgasm during the show best see the
house full body
what music was it it was just like a a
full harmonic performance so it was like
they're doing like a bunch of different
you know like a lot of bassoon a lot of
vibration yeah yeah you think this was
self-reported it was self-reported
orgasm no it was it was loud enough that
multiple attendees reported hearing a
moaning noise at one point during
someone was playing the rusty trombone
yeah
exactly it was during Tchaikovsky's
Fifth Symphony oh that's a good one
takashi's so sex oriented
before I think that'll make me squirt a
little bit
no it goes
and then she's like oh and then so
reportedly she reportedly she screamed
during the fifth
did she scream oh [__] oh [__] I'm
coming I'm [__] coming shut up yeah
she actually that's what it said yeah
yeah yeah that's what the media says
well she had a true orgasm there yeah no
there was a a group of a gasp in the
audience people couldn't believe yeah
that this chick was actually being moved
this hard by the music and like I'm
saying maybe it was perhaps the way the
harmonics is in the Philharmonic maybe
the building design was like perfect huh
maybe it's just that good it's angled
just right to hit her clitoris
oh is there a bassoon guy getting all
close to her going
like this
and then she's like
yeah she no she
this is a 4D show the media failed to
mention that so it felt like a rather
lovely expression of somebody who was
transported uh who's so transported that
it had some kind of effect on them is
what a concert goer who's a music agent
said I wish they could confirm if it was
like real or if she was just like a
freaking weirdo well apparently
um
a fellow concert girl I'm not kidding
describe the moment as quite beautiful
um and then they say to the LA Times
They say I saw the girl after it
happened and I assumed that she had an
orgasm because she was breathing heavily
her partner was smiling at her while
looking at her the entire time and then
the the other audience who was around
this chick they're like yeah this [__]
was coming baseball they're like this
[__] was [__] was she like going
essentially yeah
choke me choke me you [__]
hahaha
laughs
she probably had vibrating underwear
dude that's what it was like those Tick
Tock ads
yo he was on his phone dude quit playing
with their [__]
on Instagram I followed this page called
discover ocean right okay and it's like
they have like cool ocean videos and
[__] but recently it got hacked and it
has like five million [__] okay it
got hacked and then now they have a
bunch of like sex toys ads and like like
only fans just like like ads instead of
the ocean yeah and one of them was like
vibrating underwear and I was like well
let me take a look you know but you
liked it yeah I think I'm gonna I think
I'm gonna get it it's free shipping it's
for boys no it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be that sounds kind of
fun you know what I mean so someone
tweeted went to see at La Phil which is
their Twitter account
uh play Thelma Scotties and
Tchaikovsky's fifth last night a woman
in the audience a loud and full body
orgasm during the fifth second movement
the band politely carried on almost like
when the Titanic was sinking
The Show Must Go On does that ever
happen at other concerts like that had
to have happened when freaking Black
Eyed Peas came out with let's get it
started
because that was such a bagger yeah that
was really good the base on that that
doesn't happen no nobody else is as good
as Tchaikovsky come on I opened my
sister's wedding which was devastating
for me obviously for many reasons but I
am I am seed my sister's wedding and I I
actually said um
I was like hey you know in the words of
the immortal R Kelly which you could say
back then Immortal The Immortal Immortal
this is like 2005. yeah okay in the
words of the immortal R Kelly my mind's
telling me no but my body my body's
telling me yes to this Union
and the car went nuts
that is a banger too yeah I
have heard of different uh
not music but like I have heard
different random things making people
have orgasms that are not like like what
like stretching working out too odd not
me I heard I'm not gay like
oh yeah maybe is that working out yeah
working out there there's these videos
of these girls they're busting nuts
while they're working out yeah
wait for real your body's just going
into like us a certain amount of
shocking and just
and then they bust knots yeah this is
like a video of this girl doing a
pull-up and then she bought something
she's like shaking and like doing a poem
that's why she starts laughing and she's
like yeah that basically was an orgasm
what I mean basically because if you say
that like I'm insecure now from pull-ups
I mean maybe did I get you there or not
allegedly it was probably an orgasm I
mean that that's what she's that's what
she's saying those spiritual
everything's fake those random spiritual
things are like you know meditative and
or breathing things that like put people
into orgasmic experiences and stuff like
that too right so I mean there's got to
be like different weird triggers that
can become orgasmic or climactic talk
about like breathing classes yeah like
yeah the reason why I think that I could
understand this the reason why I think
this story is fake
is because I have never heard that a
woman can come
right I'm right with you there brother
maybe they shouldn't really
right yeah I I think it's allowed so
when you hear like women can come
multiple times you're just like just
like this is yeah that's when people
like oh yeah like you know
you made it in the lab or whatever I'm
like
women coming is propaganda yeah it's to
make men feel insecure who started that
it's feminist movement exactly it's it's
also they're trying to stop the nuclear
family it's also very
um it seems possible it's round earth
[__] not to get too woke on you guys the
round earth is there to convince you
that you're small right oh there's so
many universes and billion times [__]
galaxies and all [__] 100 million
[__] galaxies so you need to feel
this [__] bit yeah and that's exactly
what this female orgasm shit's about
it's like hey guys like they're
weaponizing it yeah yeah they're like
hey you know here's something that you
can never actually pull off yeah that
[__] experience all the time and I'm
like yeah dude okay is that true
maybe they're just saving your ego
because they feel so bad that you can't
pull off on yourself no I looked it up
that's not one of them I think that's I
looked it up another actually I think
that's probably I think it's um
to check my work uh-huh well yeah same
Source engine right right and it was
also a male who who also believes the
same
who created the smart man he's telling
us
[Laughter]
Steve's right I don't think I've ever
had an orgasm believe oh man you you
thought yeah you thought you did and no
that's fine that's okay and nobody can
blame you yeah right right I mean that
was on you you're being vulnerable yeah
that's okay you're being taken advantage
turtle's always confused anyway so we
could give her up this is true this is
true wait is it true I'm
oh it seems true yeah true yeah true
yeah it's true yeah yeah you thought
some things this is weird which
instrument made her come the hardest
because then I learned about I'll learn
that one guys
the clarinet it's a clarinet yeah it's a
triangle you think no one's seen this La
Philharmonic so this is just a fake
story of just trying to get more dude
dude it's a loose cannon marketing guy
that they hired that is such a good you
want to put parts of those seats
you got to tell people these ladies are
having orgasms full bodies it's all
listen hard
the next Show's sold out all channels
because they're like I haven't came in
[__] years it's like Suburban House
moms yeah all middle-aged women just
like come on give me Tchaikovsky yeah
where's the [__] fit play the fifth
you [__] idiot back to the fan Encore
but only the fifth
they're playing at the point fifth this
is gonna take forever I love about the
Loose Cannon marketing yeah women are
like let's get ready to fake this [__]
it doesn't play by the rules this is a
plant story this is fake Jade is like
there's no way the female orgasm is real
he might say he's the only one that
could deliver it yeah no that's a fair
argument most recent tweet he says I
have never seen a Star Wars movie you
keep your stupid [__] movie I made
millions of dollars that's what he said
that's really what he said that's what
he said how do you feel about that as a
Star Wars fan
um the stair Wars I feel like I'm not a
millionaire so he's doing something
right I'm doing something wrong
just watching two Star Wars that's all
it is yeah a bunch of a little less it'd
be fun
[Music]